Nó này mục sau tháng 30,000 hành hình khu chăm 30,
tỏa như dân thành phố chiming sế sử dư thầm,
đứa phạt bị cao nguyễn và lình,
30,000 sấu tội, 1 hạt tiếng, 1 án từ hình về tự dịch người.
Theo cao trạc, 1 giám số 4 bệ quen nhà tạm giữ con găng thành phố thu đức,
thành phố chiming cú, có hai nít từ 4 bệ tạm giám.
Trong đó, nguyễn và lình được những người bị tạm giám cùng vùng
vùng phân công làm chưởng vùng, và ngó khoảng tụ được phân công làm phó buồn.
Tạm giận 1 tạm giữ một tháng 20,000 hành hình khu chăm 30,
tố phân công bệnh người dật bùng mềnh,
dởi chánh và về sinh dụ cụ lấy cân cho cá buồn.
Đến mười dơ 3 mì phút cùng ngày,
thơ ra nhận cơm, đồ ăn theo quy định
những người được phân công chưa về sinh sòn các dụ cụ lấy cơm.
Lúc này, tố chử với yếu cầu những người này nguyễn sếp thành hẳng án.
Lên có chử về dùng trên đà chúng vào người của bệnh người này.
Sau khi bị lình đà chúng vào người anh tế có bệnh bị có dật,
suy bọn mẹt, khó thử, nên được những người bị tạm 3 chung bùng đỡ lên bệnh bệnh từ ngắm.
Cung lúc này, các mộ chực cơm như là của nhà tạm giữ phát hiện sự việc ninh báo cho chị bàn.
khi cân bộ đến mở cụ bùng ra, anh tế đã khó thử,
mặt nha đưa đi cấp cứu, nhưng đã từ vòng chút khi nhập việt.
Theo cứ lận giám định, là nhân tử vòng gió suy tình hoàn cấp,
suy tìm gió tổn thường lút nghĩ thích sòn ngoại lực.
Hành vi đã một cái vàng hình tế có thể phát hộ quả sĩnh đến tử vòng.
Tại các quan đưa ra, linh 2 nhận tổn bộ hành viên như trên.
Giờ đến của liên đã buổi thương năm trước đồng và người đại dịch thật phát của anh tế có đơn sinh bãi
và khu yếu cầu bối thường dí thêm.